have you got their hands on their hands
okay that's a good point
what happens is aki we think that the
cure is in the one reciting the quran
we think the cure is in the one that's
making the dua
so this is dangerous ground because
what's happening is yeah they've
they're holding their heads okay i don't
know if that's from the sunnah
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the 90s
moschino
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another video um
before i start i want to praise allah
the most merciful the most trust or
praise his glory and gratitude belongs
to him for the works that we do
i'm here with mohammed hijab salaam
you're right you're right yeah uh wake
up please because you know every time
you do a video with me you're flipping
sleeping and i see an insult to someone
like me with the subscriber base that i
have
oh yeah let's let's congratulate you for
having uh where's half a million
subscribers now
i thought you're going to shake my hand
i feel going to shake my mind yeah just
wake up please
yeah yeah i'm awake
today we're going to be reacting to
something important so uh we came
together actually well mama did i
message me what's up is it i'm going to
see brother zeeshan as usual he's a
regular here i'm not
and i thought you know it'd be nice to
see the brothers been a long time came
here i got some nice baklava
and we had some tea over it but it's
always it's always good to have the
champ
chump connection yes
yes
so in ma'am country they say eat sweet
and talk sweet i personally believe
we're not here to mock anybody we're not
here to talk about specific groups or
sex
we just genuinely want to understand
what's the logic behind what's about to
happen
so he's called the choo choo period if
i'm a mistake on a
trip trip i don't know yeah okay
have you got their hands on their hands
okay that's a good point so yeah they've
got
okay they've got their hands like this
yeah yeah
from what i was told correct me
correct me wrong but the true truth the
thing that he's doing i don't know if
it's a vibration i don't know if it's a
dua i don't know if it's the wind
but it's to receive it okay i don't know
i don't need some kind of ritual like
i don't know they're all doing it
[Laughter]
listen
[Laughter]
this guy's is of destroying the whole
[Laughter]
that was disclaimer that's my attack
okay let's just see okay
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it is it is it is funny i'm so
sorry let's carry on here
now guys i'm so sorry yeah if they're
they're not watching this i'm thinking
about what
what will just happen now contradicts
our statement it doesn't because
when i used to mock twice
no it's ridiculous like genuinely
brother says
it's ridiculous and you know what's
really funny you know what's really
funny
this is not in pakistan this is not in
um
south
[Laughter]
guys this is north of the country yeah
okay this is happening in britain
in the west in 2018 or 2019 guys
can you believe that a group of people i
don't even know if they paid to go to
the hall yeah i won't be surprised if
they
had tickets being sold yet and you've
got people living in britain
in the west it doesn't matter i'm not
trying to say the worst is some place
enlightenment i'm just saying
come on and they've got their hands on
their head these are uncles
aunties young people yeah desperate
people there
and this guy is there
and doing true yeah look let's come in
watching let's carry on watching
okay now look he's doing some kind of
action yeah i don't know if that's one
of getting the beats together stopping
blowing okay let's suppose argument's
sake yeah he's doing it he's reading the
door and he's
blowing it on there okay the question
that needs to be asked is the following
yeah because
with these kind of things when it
happens you need to understand as human
beings we are weak
okay now in my culture in my family like
i said before they what they do is
um they get coffee they drink it they
turn it upside down wait for a little
bit turn it and see animals and say oh
you're gonna get married that's gonna
happen
now most of the times there is a saying
in turkish yeah they say
don't believe it's called fun means
fortune telling don't believe in the
fortune telling but don't go without it
so i'll repeat again don't believe the
fortune telling
but don't go without it now what that
means is in a sense
don't believe it but there's no harm in
looking at it
now what happens is let's put ourselves
in a situation okay
because in this situation you're either
going to laugh or cry at the matter i'll
be honest promises
it's it's a crying matter or a laughing
matter we're laughing because
it's sad to see the state of desperate
people who might be have marriage issues
family might have disease or whatever it
may be and they're in a desperate
situation
now if you go to this guy and we know
for example from the quran
subhanallah says there are jinns who go
to the certain heavens and try to get
information what does allah
say about those genes that do that do
they gather that information
yeah i would say i would say that these
are two separate issues though like with
this
i don't think there's any fortune
telling going on no but they can be
connected so okay let me put it like
this here
innocent boy who wants innocent let's
see your sister yeah once you get
married
not working and you know in today's time
black magic see her someone did this
someone did that
she goes to this event and in this event
for example let's suppose
what this particular event is let's
suppose any particular event
yeah any particular event she goes to
yeah or let's suppose she has a pain i'm
just giving an argument yeah
after she attends this event it stops
what will be the first thing that comes
to her mind
what should i be thinking she'll think
that she'll actually she may attribute
that
to to the thing that happened in the
event thank you now
if she ascribes that to this person and
there's a reoccurrence of things
happening
positive things when ever she visits
this specific period or the specific
event or this
let's say wherever they are yeah and
let's talk about all aspects of life
christians hindus
whoever does this kind of stuff here if
they attend that
where is their iman growing towards
towards allah or the individual or the
act that's been done
well the act could be could be
attributed but remember there could be
sunnah acts and there could be
yes acts which are not sunnah which i
think is where the crux of this
discussion should be because the
question here is
is what's happening here in line with
the sunnah according to any of the
mother
if it like if someone is a hanafi or if
someone is a shareholder if it's a
melaki or hambury
if from the four schools of sunni
orthodoxy yeah
is this what's going on is this detailed
in any of the books or
that i should be that i should look into
i'll be interested to find
such a thing if there is if there's a
narration on such a
prayer of blowing and i would like to
see such a narration
uh authentically transmitted from the
prophet muhammad
but that is why it's important to look
at
the sunnah through that lens okay i mean
there is going to be difference of
opinion
but there are things which are outside
of the pale of that difference of
opinion
that's why it's very important to always
um
i mean you don't want to go into
extremes with this but there is a hadith
which says that the prophet muhammad
said
whoever invents into this religion or to
this affair of ours
which is not part of it then it's
rejected okay
like the diet that he made at the end
look i haven't got a problem though
is there's a hadith that says it's the
it's the bone marrow of if you like the
crux of
worship and that's a weak hadith and
there's about hadith
it's the actual i better itself so this
is a beneficial thing that's taking
place but
what's preceded it is simply something
which is unprecedented but what if okay
look one second job even if we said
there's evidence from the quran in the
sunnah for example when it comes to a
specific let's say somebody making dua
for you
when it's done in a situation where
there's a mass gathering if there's
money involved
and there's a issue or a a great area
where individuals in there they might be
ignorant
yeah yeah i don't know if there was
money involved in that particular
government
as far as i know i was thought it was
but i don't know i was told that there
was money involved yeah okay okay and
this
person goes around the country right so
now i'm saying when money is involved
when people's emotions are involved when
desperation is involved and now
the point is this is let's say some
quran of course someone can make dua for
you
now if a person is like rookia what
happens is
anyone could do a rookie probably you
can read qur'an on yourself you can get
someone to read it
but why do we got iraqis why and doesn't
certain iraqis which we know which
happened two years ago
yes manipulating the situation some do
some
the point is this that what happens is
as human beings we're created with allah
says we've
created mankind what happens is aki we
think that the cure is in the one
reciting the quran
we think the cure is in the one that's
making the dua
so this is dangerous ground because
what's happening is they
they're holding their heads okay i don't
know if that's from the sunnah it's not
from the sun okay
i i mean there's there's nothing in this
one i've
i'd like to once again see the
narrations so now with these things
there's extremes which you've done a
video about on your channel where
there's a naked pier
and he's got people touching him or
you've got another person
they're bowing down to him but you can
check that in the brotherhood's channel
this is dangerous and what we're just
seeing is
put us to a site yeah you can call us
wahhabi whatever you want to call it
logically brothers and sisters it's not
i don't even think this is a matter of
what
is it i'm saying look look put us
together or salafism or diobandism i
think this is just about
sunni orthodoxy exactly going back to
the form of that
exactly so i would say what advice would
you give to someone because look i've
been in situations maybe you've been in
situations where
i was in desperation there's been
situations where i thought i have no way
to go out and i speak into brothers who
have been in similar situations
where they would end up because they're
in such a desperate situation they would
go to individuals
and these individuals say okay take this
dig this there put this to this tree
read this and because you're in such a
desperate situation you're not there
it's not your you're a person that's
under the influence and what happens
brothers and sisters in this desperate
situation is the very moment
that your tahiti really shine and your
trust in allah should really really
your tawa quran allah should be seen
what happens is in the desperate
situation people tend to go to these
people
and i know brother who said i paid
thousands of pounds
to these people who have told me go to
the here do this you'll get this person
back
what advice would you give to people
like that in those desperate situations
where they're thinking you know what
because human beings actually we like to
see that's why a lot of people are
inclined to [ __ ] why
because it's the object that they can
see touch and feel yes with allah and
the reward for gender is why because you
believe in him when you don't see it and
just to be clear we're not saying this
[ __ ] took place in that video
i don't think there's evidence that any
[ __ ] took place in that video unless
something has been said in order that i
don't know what's being said yeah i'm
talking about your channel yeah just
just to make that clear right but
uh i think what i would say look there's
two things you need to be very clear of
that there's
in islam there is a direct relationship
between man
a woman on the one hand and god on the
other right
the quran says understand you alone we
worship when you're alone we ask for
help
and that is in the second person so
you're speaking to allah directly and
this is something we have to recite 17
times a day at least
which means that we have a direct
connection with allah and
you can make diet to allah yourself you
don't need any intermediary or anybody
or any human being
or any wise person or guru or
sheikh or peer or whatever it is to do
that you can make
dua to allah yourself number two is
make sure that what you're doing the
action that you are performing is in
line
with sunny orthodoxy as per any of the
motherhood
no one i'm not saying oh you have to be
this man well that method will follow
this
year any of the motherhood which are uh
bona fide and legitimized in the sunni
school of thought
you follow those yeah but make sure that
you're not going overboard
because if it's something which has not
been done or spoken of by the scholars
of islam
for 100 years and it's just something
that you're doing
right gimmicky it's gimmicky and it's
new and it's innovative
then it has nothing to do with the
sunnah of the prophet muhammad
and in fact it is an invention or an
innovation into the religion and so yeah
there is something called bid
in the religion
would say this every time he would he
would ascend the pulpit
uh the minbar he would mention the bidha
which is an in innovation into the
religion so we don't want to fall into
those innovations
okay but we don't want to label
everything and everybody has innovators
and
everything is innovation but we don't
want to fall into the innovation as well
does it
these kind of actions give birth to the
other extremes yeah you know so brothers
and sisters look i'll tell you
personally i'll talk from personal
experience
i've been in situations i've needed
specific dwarfs to be answered
and i had i could have easily broken
sisters go and be like okay yeah
let me go to this period because you're
in a vulnerable position i've been there
i know
friends around me who've been in that
situation but having
firmness sticking to tahit knowing that
allah
you need to understand something the one
who's created the heavens and the earth
i'm telling you those who are who have
marriage problems those who want to get
married those who have illnesses
those who have whatever problems you
have the one who's created heaven is in
the earth
is it do you really think it's hard for
allah to answer your dua no it's not
but allah is going to put you through
certain tests and trials
will answer your dua sometimes question
yourself is it my sins is it certain
things i'm doing
question yourself sometimes and this is
the things i did i reflected okay
my advice not being answered can i
answer my dua yes does he exist
yes the question is there is something
that i'm missing here
do not spoil that by going to people
whoever they may be whichever group
they're from
and think okay this person can help me
never
what advice i'm giving to you from
personal experiences
allah and i find the faults in myself
and fix those faults and once you fix
your affairs with allah allah will fix
your face with the people
so a reminder from this video besides
the whole thing that we
think it's wrong is the fact that i have
trust in allah
you can worship him alone you don't need
to go to some uh christian priest and
confess your sins
you don't need to go to some rabbi and
please please
this is a good point because just on
this like especially where money is
involved in the equation this was one of
the main reasons protestantism
in this in the 16th century actually
became very popular
yeah these things called indulgences
that um catholic priests would
do so people would go to catholic
priests and they would pay the money to
basically forgive their sins and so on
and this actually continues to this day
this these so-called indulgences it
continues to say
and that was one of the points that
protestant reformers
said look what corruption is going on in
the church which made people
uh leave catholicism and not only this
but
in the modern age it's making catholics
leave religion altogether
and this is what the prophet said and
it's very important he told us that
you will follow the the path of the jews
and the christians
you know uh even so that if you go and
if a lizard goes it goes into a hole you
go into it
like the lizard in other words we are
going to follow the the destructive path
of the previous dispensations and what
i'm saying to you
guys is that this is clearly
um if not religious fraud
fraud if you want to put it that way or
it's a scandal really in the religious
community of islam
it would at least lead to that if it's
not that itself exactly you know so
you know when it comes to money people
come over here and i'm not saying
everything that's a religious service
should
shouldn't be should be free that's not
true either that's not true if someone's
teaching quran
and we're not saying that they shouldn't
be able to charge for that or even
we're not saying there's no situation
where money should be exchanged
or hijab or any of those things teaching
but what we are saying is if someone
claims to give you curing ability
that's only from allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and the quran
is a cure itself okay the quran is it
calls itself a shift which is a cure
and your connection of allah is direct
you don't require any human being on the
face of the earth
in order to to trespass in order to to
go through
as an intermediary to get to allah
exactly pronounce this will end on that
no inshallah do not forget to change
video on a naked pair and we'll find out
why he's naked
um until next time